Salut, c’est Juliette.
Vous avez peut-être déjà vu mes messages passer sur les réseaux de Brut.
En gros, j’ai lancé une messagerie
et je demandais aux gens
de témoigner anonymement
par rapport au harcèlement
qu’ils avaient subi.
Moi, je m’attendais vite fait à recevoir
quelques messages…
Salut Brut,
j’appelle pour laisser mon témoignage…
J’ai fini par… faire une dépression…
...à devenir la bête noire du lycée..
Mais je m’attendais pas du tout
au nombre de messages que j’ai reçus.
Le téléphone n’a pas arrêté de sonner
pendant une semaine
et je pense qu'en tout,
j’ai reçu plus de 1000 messages.
J’ai fait plusieurs tentatives de suicide…
Aller à l’école avec la boule au ventre…
Avoir peur d’y aller le lendemain.
Les chiffres officiels
disent que 700 000 enfants
se font harcelés en France.
Ça ferait 5 à 6% des élèves.
Mais en vrai, je pense que
c’est encore beaucoup plus élevé
vu la quantité de messages
que  j’ai reçus sur le répondeur.
Franchement,
arrêtez de faire subir ça,
c’est pas humain...
C’est juste carrément pas possible.
Je trouve qu’on ne parle pas du tout assez
du harcèlement en France.
Du coup, aujourd’hui, je vais
vous raconter l’histoire de Dinah.
Elle avait 14 ans et elle était méga proche
de son grand frère, Rayan.
Que cuisinez-vous, madame, aujourd’hui ?
- Alors, aujourd’hui, je cuisine
un petit poulet au barbecue !
- Un petit poulet au barbecue ?
Et qu’est-ce que vous avez mis comme marmelade dessus ?
- Alors là…
faut pas me demander.
Sia version rebeu.
Vas-y, chante.
On avait six ans d’écart mais
je ne les voyais pas, moi,
les six ans d’écart,
enfin,
on était vraiment proches.
Je lui parlais de tout,
elle me parlait de tout.
Enfin, c’était vraiment…
c’était assez fusionnel,
quand même.
"Will never let you goooo…
This tiiiiime."
- Je griffe.
- Miaou !
Arrêtez !
Mais ouais, j’aimais bien aussi la taquiner,
du coup,
la voir
se vexer, ça me faisait rire et du coup,
elle rigolait au final,
mais ouais, on rigolait pas mal.
Bouh !
On a pratiquement
les mêmes goûts musicaux,
du coup, on se retrouvait beaucoup dans ça.
Enfin, on s’envoyait des playlists,
des chansons à écouter, etc.
Et puis quand je rentrais à la maison,
du coup, ben,
des fois on faisait des petits duos
sur des chansons d’Angèle,
parce qu’elle aimait beaucoup Angèle,
donc sur des chansons d’Angèle, par exemple.
Vas-y !
- Tu me fais rigoler !
Elle était très mature pour son âge.
Elle avait déjà un regard sur des sujets,
sur la politique, sur…
sur plein de choses
qui étaient déjà bien ancrées en elle.
Elle était très, très intelligente.
Elle voulait être présidente de la République.
Je suis…
très proche de ma mère,
ma sœur aussi était très proche de ma mère.
À la maison, on parle vraiment de tout,
il n’y a pas de tabou,
c’est très ouvert,
on a une confiance absolue en nous tous.
En 2020, Rayan quitte Mulhouse
pour faire ses études loin de chez lui
et, du coup, loin de sa petite sœur.
Dinah, elle est en 4e.
Sa mère commence à sentir
que Dinah ne va pas trop bien,
mais au début, Dinah lui dit rien.
Finalement, elle lui avoue qu’elle a
des petits soucis avec ses copines.
Son comportement commence à changer.
Elle ne veut plus aller à l’école,
elle fait genre qu’elle est malade
pour rater les cours
et le soir, elle laisse des messages
sous l’oreiller de sa mère
en la suppliant de ne pas l’emmener
au collège le lendemain.
Les premières causes de son harcèlement, c’était parce que c’était une
très, très bonne élève.
Elle avait des super bonnes notes et
elle posait beaucoup de questions en classe.
Ça, ça avait le don d'agacer
certaines personnes,
mais je pense qu’on a tous déjà vécu ça,
enfin, on connaissait la personne
qui posait trop de questions
et après, on souffle quand elle pose trop de questions, ça nous garde dans la classe,
à la fin on lui dit "attends à la sortie, tu vas voir."
Bah elle, c’était ça.
Elle n’arrivait pas à s’exprimer en classe,
parce que dès qu’elle ouvrait la bouche,
ça sifflait de partout, en fait.
Tout le monde l’engueulait,
tout le monde l’insultait,
tout le monde la traitait,
tout le monde disait : "Oh merde, encore toi.
Encore elle."
On la prenait en photo en cachette.
Ou quelqu'un qui est assis derrière elle
va taper sur sa chaise
pendant 1 heure, mais sans s'arrêter.
Et ça, tous les jours.
Elle m’a jamais dit que ça durait
toute l'heure du cours.
Et…
Changer de place aussi.
En fait, je suis allée voir un prof,
c'était pendant la rencontre parents-profs,
et je lui ai dit :
"Est-ce qu'elle peut changer de place ?
Vous l’avez mise entre deux personnes qui l'empêchent de…"
Et il m’a dit : "Oui, mais vous savez, nous, on fait un roulement, en fait,
tous les 3 mois ou tous les 6 mois."
J’ai dit : "Oui mais d’accord,
mais là, c’est moi qui vous le demande,
on ne parle pas de roulement, vous l’enlevez, elle en a marre."
"Ah mais Dinah, il fallait le dire !"
Mais Dinah, elle a dit :
"Mais je vous l’ai dit !"
Et après, il l’a changée de place.
Dans les couloirs, on va la bousculer,
on va la frapper,
on va l’insulter.
Même quand elle rentrait,
ça continuait vu qu’il y avait les réseaux,
il y avait WhatsApp, il y avait Snapchat,
enfin, il y avait tous ces réseaux-là.
Donc ma mère, ce qu’elle a dû faire,
c’est qu’elle a dû bloquer les appels et les messages et…
pendant une certaine heure.
Et elle lui débloquait juste le soir
après avoir fait ses devoirs.
Et dans un laps de temps précis.
Et elle a bloqué tous les contacts, enfin,
on ne pouvait pas l’appeler dans la journée,
il n’y avait que les numéros
de mon père, ma mère et moi
qui pouvions la contacter dans la journée.
Eh, eh, eeeeh !
Eh, eh, eeeh !
Pourquoi t’as peur comme ça ?
- T’as vu ? Il t’aime pas.
Elle s’enfermait dans sa chambre,
elle ne parlait plus trop…
C'était bizarre,
enfin, ce n'était plus
la Dinah qu’on avait connue.
Rayan et sa mère
s'inquiètent beaucoup pour Dinah
et quand elle entre en 3e,
son harcèlement devient encore plus violent.
Elle avait un groupe de copines,
de base, elles étaient, ouais,
6, 7, je pense.
Elle a commencé à dire qu’elle s'intéressait
au courant LGBT
et que peut-être qu'elle aimait les filles
et les garçons en même temps et que,
bah voilà, c'était elle.
Donc elle s'est confiée à son groupe de copines
et il y a deux de ce groupe-là
qui lui ont fait croire
qu'elles étaient amoureuses d'elle.
Je pense qu’elles ont soufflé
le chaud et le froid avec Dinah.
C’était "je t’aime moi non plus".
Et Dinah, elle tombait toujours dans le piège.
Et comme elles connaissaient son point faible,
et son point faible, entre guillemets,
c’était sa sensibilité,
donc elles ont joué de ça.
Au bout de quelques semaines, elles ont dit : "Mais tu crois vraiment qu’on
était amoureuses toi et moi ?
Jamais de la vie.
Tu es une ignominie de la société."
Et du coup, ce groupe-là
a propagé au sein de la classe,
et du coup, ça s'est propagé dans le collège parce que c'est rapide.
À partir de là, il y avait déjà le fait que,
du coup, ce soit l'intello,
le fait que ce soit la lesbienne,
et en fait, après, tout ce qu'elle faisait,
c'était critiqué.
C'était… On parlait dessus, elle pouvait
mettre un jogging, elle se faisait insulter,
elle pouvait mettre un pantalon,
elle se faisait insulter.
Enfin, c'était vraiment pour tous ses faits
et gestes qu'elle se faisait critiquer.
Allez, j’y vais.
- Bonne chance.
- Merci.
Elle a fait une première tentative en mars.
Elle avait pris des médicaments et du coup,
elle est restée à l'hôpital
une ou deux semaines, je crois.
Je suis rentré le jour où elle,
elle est rentrée aussi à la maison.
Je l’ai vue quand je suis rentré,
je lui ai beaucoup parlé.
Et elle m’a dit :
"Oui mais ne t'inquiète pas, je ne referai plus ça.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi j’ai fait ça,
je ne le referai plus."
Ses copines étaient au courant,
parce qu’on a appris aussi très récemment que
ma sœur, elle leur disait,
pendant qu’elle faisait sa tentative de suicide, elle leur disait :
"Je vais faire ma tentative de suicide,
je suis en train de la faire."
Et quand elle s’est réveillée après ça,
elle n'a reçu aucun message.
Rien. Ses copines n’ont rien fait.
Elle m’avait montré un message
où elles parlaient sur WhatsApp,
et Dinah parlait avec, et puis les filles
se parlaient entre elles,
mais elles faisaient comme si
Dinah n’existait pas, en fait,
dans cette conversation.
Et elle m’a montré son téléphone, elle m’a dit : "Qu'est-ce que tu lis ?
Qu'est-ce que tu comprends ?"
Et je lui ai dit :
"Je comprends qu’elles te lisent
mais elles ont décidé, entre elles,
peut-être qu’elles ont un groupe
à côté que tu connais pas,
et qu’entre elles, elles se disent :
"Venez, on fait ça."
On fait comme si elle n'était pas là."
Après ça, on l’a beaucoup surveillée.
Enfin, moi, après, je suis resté à la maison quand même assez longtemps
et on l’a beaucoup, beaucoup surveillée
parce qu’on avait peur.
Enfin, moi, je sais que
quand j’étais en bas, je montais,
je mettais une alarme et je montais
toutes les vingt minutes
ou alors j’appelais dans les escaliers
pour voir si elle était toujours là.
Et, encore une fois,
j’avais l'impression de la punir
parce qu'elle était constamment surveillée,
et je pense que ça devait être
encore une pression pour elle,
mais c’était pour elle
et c'était pour sa sécurité.
Elle est restée à la maison je crois une ou deux semaines après son hospitalisation,
et le jour même
où elle est retournée au collège,
on nous a appelés
pour nous dire de venir la chercher.
Elle voulait plus trop aller en cours, enfin,
à chaque fois,
elle essayait de trouver des excuses
et elle essayait d’esquiver un peu
l'école alors qu’elle adore ça,
c'est juste que les gens,
elle ne voulait pas les voir, en fait.
Ma sœur a reçu une lettre…
Enfin, en fait, elle leur a fait une lettre
pour leur dire :
"Reprenez-moi dans le groupe,
je me sens mal d'être toute seule.
Je m’excuse de ce que je vous ai fait,
même si je ne sais pas ce que je vous ai fait.
Je veux juste…"
Elle n'aimait pas être seule, ma sœur.
Elle aimait être entourée.
Ces personnes-là ont répondu par une lettre :
"Jamais de la vie
on te reprendra dans le groupe.
Tu as essayé de te tuer une fois,
t'as pas réussi,
ben la prochaine fois,
on te donnera des liens
pour te montrer comment
tu peux réussir à te suicider, ne t'inquiète pas.
Tu ne mérites pas de vivre."
Enfin, que des choses comme ça, c’était vraiment horrible.
Finalement, en juin 2021,
Dinah termine le collège.
C’est les vacances, elle part au Maroc,
elle a l’impression
que ses soucis sont derrière elle.
En septembre, elle va recommencer
dans un nouveau lycée,
où elle ne sera pas avec ses harceleuses.
Elle fait sa rentrée, elle est super excitée
de retourner en cours.
Mais un jour,
elle recroise ses harceleuses.
Personne ne sait exactement
ce qu’elles se disent ce jour-là,
mais en tout cas,
le 5 octobre,
Dinah n’en peut plus de sa vie.
Vers
2h, 3h du matin,
je reçois un appel de ma mère
qui me dit : "Ah salut, Rayan, ça va ?"
avec une voix bien réveillée.
Et je lui dis : "Oui,
mais il est quelle heure, là ?"
Elle me dit : "Il est 3h."
Je lui dis : "Mais pourquoi tu m’appelles ?"
Elle me dit : "Mais tu dors ?"
Je lui dis : "Bah oui, il est 3h."
Et elle me dit : "Beh, rendors-toi."
Je lui dis : "Ben non maman, tu m’appelles à
3h du matin, c’est qu’il y a un problème."
Et là, je sens que sa voix, elle tremble.
Et, instinctivement, j’ai tout de suite compris qu’il y avait un problème avec ma sœur.
Et elle me dit : "C’est Dinah."
Et c’était exactement le même schéma
que sa première tentative de suicide.
Et elle me dit, avant de raccrocher :
"Il faut que tu rentres à la maison.
J’ai besoin de toi."
Et là, en fait, mon père venait de lui dire
que son cœur avait lâché
et, du coup, ma mère m’appelle
et elle hurle au téléphone.
Elle répétait : "Je n’ai plus de fille.
J’ai perdu ma fille, je n’ai plus de fille.
Rayan, il faut que tu rentres à la maison."
Elle ne devrait pas être là.
Elle ne devrait pas être là,
ce n’est pas possible.
Je me dis que ce n’est pas possible.
C’est un truc de fou,
ça me rend fou,
ça me rend vraiment fou.
Elle n’a rien à faire ici.
Même les cours, je n’arrive plus du tout à suivre. C’est horrible.
Je n’y arrive plus.
Pourtant, j’ai toujours voulu faire psycho,
et je me suis donné pour venir
à la fac de psycho de Bordeaux,
et c’est hyper intéressant,
c’est juste que mon esprit, il n’est pas…
Je n’y arrive pas.
Je n’y arrive vraiment pas,
je n’arrive plus à rien du tout.
Vraiment.
De base, je veux être psychologue
dans l’armée.
Mais là, au vu des événements,
je pense que je vais me tourner
vers psychologue
dans la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse.
Du coup, là, je vais partir à Bordeaux
et, en fait, la première fois que
j’ai rencontré Rayan pour faire ce reportage,
c’était aussi à Bordeaux.
Donc ça fait un peu une boucle qui se termine.
Et là, ce soir, on va dîner avec ses colocs
qui sont aussi en psychologie.
Et du coup, ça m’intéresse un peu d’avoir
leurs points de vue par rapport à
ce qu’ils pensent, ce qui devrait être fait
sur le harcèlement en France
et pour éviter qu’une autre tragédie
comme celle de Dinah se reproduise.
Si les deux côtés n’en parlent pas
et si c’est pas sensibilisé des deux côtés…
Parce qu’on sensibilise beaucoup
pour le harcelé, ce qui est très bien,
mais il faut aussi, je pense,
sensibiliser les harceleurs
comme quoi ce n’est pas normal, en fait.
Il n’y a rien de normal
à mettre à part quelqu’un, à…
Il n’y a rien de normal.
Et je pense que
tant que des deux côtés,
il n’y pas la prévention qu’il faut,
ça va continuer.
Qu’ils fassent de la prévention dès le début…
Enfin, dès la première alerte, ben en vrai,
ça peut éviter beaucoup de choses.
Ouais, ils doivent attendre
qu’une famille…
- C’est ça.
- …en deuil passe à la télé, en fait, pour…
- Si seulement ce n’était qu’une famille.
Ma sœur, c’était la dix-neuvième.
- Et il y en a eu après, hein.
- Il y en a eu trois autres après, encore.
- Le pire, c’est qu’il y en a eu après.
Après tout ça.
Là… C’était quand ? La semaine dernière,
il y a eu une petite qui s’est aussi…
Tu te dis : "Mais ça ne s’arrête jamais !"
- Avec les réseaux sociaux, il y a un moyen de,
entre guillemets, "continuer à harceler",
même quand tu n’es pas
physiquement avec la personne.
Tu ne peux jamais bloquer
une personne entièrement.
Si elle veut recréer un compte,
elle recrée un compte.
Donc ça ne s’arrête pas, en fait.
- Je me demande si…
Parfois, je me demande
l’état d’esprit des gens qui ont harcelé
ma sœur à l’heure actuelle.
Qu’est-ce qu’ils se disent ?
Est-ce qu’ils dorment correctement ?
Est-ce qu’ils ont envie de venir
chez nous pour s’expliquer ?
Est-ce qu’ils sont totalement indifférents ? Est-ce qu’ils s’en veulent ?
Est-ce qu’ils ont conscience
de tout ce qu’ils ont fait ?
Je ne sais pas.
Pour nous,
c’est trop tard, vu que Dinah n’est plus là.
Mais pour les autres, il faut
qu’il y ait des choses qui soient mises en place.
Il faut qu’il y ait des lois
qui soient votées contre le harcèlement.
Il faut que les équipes pédagogiques
des établissements soient formées.
Il faut limite mettre des personnes
qui sont formées spécialement,
des psychologues ou je ne sais pas,
qui sont formées spécialement
pour ce genre de problèmes de harcèlement dans les établissements
et qui ne s’occupent vraiment que de ça.
Il ne faut vraiment pas que ce soit…
C’est un sujet encore trop tabou en France.
Et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi c’est un sujet tabou,
le harcèlement scolaire.
Le 24 février 2022,
le parlement a enfin adopté une loi
reconnaissant le harcèlement scolaire
comme un délit.
La peine pourrait grimper
à 10 ans de prison,
si les faits conduisent
la victime à se suicider.
Par contre, rien ne change
pour la famille de Dinah
car les faits se sont passés
avant le vote de la loi.
♫ Ton visage, ton sourire me hante ♫
♫ Tes câlins, tes mots doux me manquent ♫
♫ Le son de ta voix qui m’appelle ♫
♫ Je sais bien que c’est pas réel ♫
♫ Ton odeur sur tous mes vêtements ♫
♫ Tu sais bien,
ceux que tu me piquais tout le temps ♫
♫ Nos disputes, nos fous rires, nos peines ♫
♫ Nos messages, nos appels, tes "je t’aime" ♫
♫ Tes blagues qui ne voulaient rien dire ♫
♫ Moi, elles me faisaient toujours sourire ♫
♫ La douleur qui me consume maintenant ♫
♫ Me rappelle à chaque instant que ♫
♫ Je n’entendrais plus jamais ta voix ♫
♫ Mais mon cœur
ne veut pas le comprendre ♫
♫ Il me crie qu’il voudrait te revoir ♫
♫ Et chaque nuit je t’attends ♫
♫ Tu sais, j’aimerais tellement savoir ♫
♫ Si de là-haut tu pouvais me voir ♫
♫ Si de là-haut tu pouvais comprendre ♫
♫ Que sans toi plus rien n’a de sens ♫
Si vous ou un de vos proches
êtes en train de vous faire harceler,
il y a un numéro gratuit
que vous pouvez appeler,
c’est le 3020,
pour recevoir du soutien.
Le harcèlement est encore
trop tabou en France,
c’est pour ça que
vous avez probablement été si nombreux
à me laisser des messages vocaux
et c’est aussi pour ça
que je voulais faire cette vidéo aujourd’hui.
Si cette vidéo vous a intéressé,
vous pouvez vous abonner
à notre chaîne Brut. pour voir plus de contenus
et n'hésitez pas à m’envoyer un message
si vous voulez que je parle d’autres sujets
qui vous tiennent à cœur